hello and welcome to another episode of
footnotes as per the usual i'm here to
recap the most ravishing ideas from
around wired our 20th anniversary issue
is on newsstands now and in it we have
an encyclopedia of sorts under m you'll
find an entry for memes but you won't
find an entry for macaroni because we
don't really cover that here at wired
so the term meme was coined in 1976 by
richard dawkins in his book the
shellfish gene
uh matt that's actually selfish
shut up alexa you're being selfish
it is selfish
i've been on a new
allergy medication the term meme was
coined in 1976 by richard dawkins in his
book the selfish gene in which he
applies the rules of natural selection
to the spread of ideas the most
successful memes are the ones that are
the most customizable because like a
gene memes can mutate but unlike a gene
they can't be responsible for my
family's crippling fear of door handles
of course marketing types love using
memes because they can make money off of
them without ever having an original
idea witness keyboard cat selling
pistachios
keyboard cat does it perfectly
i would love to meet the guy
who woke up in the morning and decided
he wanted to sell more pistachios
so on that note let's begin a magical
journey through the internet's greatest
memes before marketers have a chance to
ruin them all the identity of techno
biking is still unknown though in
january he sued the guy that filmed him
for profiting off of his image this is a
completely uninformed recreation of that
event
dramatic chipmunk is actually a dramatic
prairie dog and is set to music from
young frankenstein
that film contains no prairie dogs
because they aren't welcome in
transylvania
the insane clown posse ought to know
that magnets work due to electrons which
themselves are tiny magnets getting
aligned to either attract or repel as a
larger force kind of like how grown men
painting their faces repel women
lol cats suck at spelling and grammar
only because they lack opposable thumbs
and cannot practice writing but
hemingway's cats had tons of extra
digits and were great writers and had
sweet beards and the occasional hangover
can you imagine cats drunk or hungover
they are as it is
the guys who did the peanut butter jelly
time song followed it up with a tune
called ice cream and cake it's
essentially the same song only it's not
really recommended for diabetics
the joseph de crow meme is actually the
artist self-portrait specifically titled
self-portrait of the artist in the guise
of a mockingbird and that's unrealistic
because mockingbirds don't wear hats
yes this dog comes from the serbian film
landscape in the mist from this movie i
decided that while i have a crippling
fear of door handles i never once shot
up face water or made a dog talk on the
phone when i clearly did not feel like
talking i think that's something to be
proud of